you're going to go for the close, okay?
My tip on that, do it on Zoom and do it in the morning
before they go to work, before the day starts.
And honestly, I've had some of my best success
doing deals on Saturday morning.
Sounds crazy, sounds weird, but guess what?
A lot of times during the week,
these guys are fricking running their business.
They're not working on their business.
They're working in their business.
So I used to schedule calls when I was actively doing them.
Now we have people in closers,
but when I was actively in 2020, on Saturday morning,
you know what I would do?
And in 2021, Saturday morning,
I would schedule a sales call for 7 a.m.
That's how I wanted to start my weekend.
I wanted to make dough by 8.30.
I had a new credit card on file and boom,
I could enjoy the weekend.
I would close, I had very, very high percentage
of closing on Saturday morning.
So my tip is do it in the morning while they're still fresh
before all the problems have,
they become inundated with problems.
And as a bonus, Saturdays seem to work very, very well.